It's This American Life. I'm Bim Adewunmi, in for Ira Glass this week. So, back in early April, when we were still only a few weeks into lockdown in New York, a friend of mine asked me what things were like on Planet Bim. It was a joke, but it was one of those accurate jokes. Because living alone right now is probably not that dissimilar to being a far away, solitary planet.
这里是《美国生活》。我是本·阿德温米，本周代班艾拉·格拉斯。回到四月初，那时纽约的居家隔离才开始几周，我的一位朋友问我“毕姆星球”上的生活是什么样的。这虽然是个玩笑，但却是一个精准的玩笑。因为一个人住现在可能和身处遥远孤独的星球没什么两样。
New York was one of the first places to lock down. And in a way, I'm still living like it's March. I work from home. I leave for groceries. I attend almost no social functions.
纽约是最早实施封锁的城市之一。从某种意义上说，我的生活仿佛还停留在三月。我在家工作。只有买杂货时才出门。几乎不参加任何社交活动。
And it's not that I don't know how to be alone. Being alone, even in a crowd, is not new to me. We moved continents when I was very young, living between the UK and Nigeria. I went off to boarding school when I was 10 years old. I left home for university when I was 19, and I never really moved back home again.
并不是我不知道如何独处。独处，即使是在人群中，对我来说也不陌生。我年纪很小时就搬过几次家，在英国和尼日利亚之间往返。我10岁就去了寄宿学校。19岁离家上大学，之后就再也没真正回过家。
I've lived in London, Lagos, Berlin, and now New York. I chose to live in those last two places, to move far away from family and home. But there's something different about the aloneness of right now.
我住过伦敦、拉各斯、柏林，现在是纽约。后两个地方是我自己选的，是为了远离家人和家乡。但现在的这种孤独感有些不同。
COVID-19 has taken away that element of choice. Like a 9-year-old being sent up to her room as punishment, versus sitting in her room, quietly reading anyway. The activities are the same, but the issue is control. So many of us have been dealing with this enforced aloneness a lot more since the pandemic began.
新冠疫情剥夺了这种选择的权利。就像一个9岁的孩子因惩罚被关进房间，与她自己坐在房间里安静地看书是不同的。活动内容一样，但核心在于掌控权。自从疫情开始，我们许多人一直在应对这种被迫的孤独。
Sometimes I feel like I'm floating through space, a sort of dwarf planet in a galaxy that seems to be populated by planets with people attached-- children, a partner, other family members, maybe even housemates or a pet. I have none of those things at the moment. My family, my parents, my siblings, their partners, they're all in London, about three and a half thousand miles and a full ocean away.
有时我觉得自己正漂浮在太空中，像是一个银河系中的矮行星，而周围满是行星，上面住满了人——孩子、伴侣、其他家庭成员，甚至室友或宠物。我现在一样都没有。我的家人、父母、兄弟姐妹和他们的伴侣，都在伦敦，远在三千五百英里外，隔着一整片大洋。
I'm basically a caricature of the elder millennial. It's just me and an ever-growing collection of house plants and candles. And as I kept thinking about space and about distance, I realized, oh, I'm not a planet. I'm an astronaut. It feels like no one is psychically, if not physically, further away from their loved ones than an astronaut in orbit.
我基本上是老千禧一代的缩影。只有我和不断增加的盆栽和蜡烛。当我不断思考空间和距离时，我意识到，哦，我不是行星，我是宇航员。那种感觉，如果不是身体上的，至少在精神上，没有谁比轨道上的宇航员离爱人更遥远。
So I found an astronaut, just to compare notes with-- Leroy Chiao. He's retired now from NASA. But altogether, he spent more than 7 and 1/2 months in space.
所以我找了一位宇航员来交流一下心得——勒罗伊·焦。他现在已经从美国国家航空航天局退休了。他在太空总共待了超过7个半月。
Can I ask a child's question now?
现在我可以问一个孩子气的问题吗？
Sure.
当然可以。
Can you be bored in space? Like, is it different to Earth boredom?
在太空会感到无聊吗？这和地球上的无聊有什么不同吗？
You know, I think you-- well, put it this way. We do have a lot to do. Even if a lot of the work is tedious work, it's still work that has to be done, and it has to be done per the schedule.
你知道，我觉得你——嗯，这么说吧。我们有很多事情要做。即使很多工作都很枯燥，但那依然是必须完成的任务，而且必须按计划完成。
And if we didn't have that, it would be a lot more difficult. Because even though you've got the spectacular view of the Earth and you're taking photographs of all these great places, after a while, if you didn't have enough to do, it'd be pretty tough, you know?
如果我们没有这些工作，日子会难过得多。因为尽管你能看到地球的壮丽景色，拍摄所有这些伟大的地方，但过了一阵子，如果你没有足够的事情做，那会非常艰难，你知道吗？
So the answer is yes. I think he was saying yes, you can absolutely get bored in space, even though they keep them quite busy. Leroy told me something I hadn't known. At the end of every day, all the activities on the International Space Station had to be logged. And every single day, based on that log, the plan changed.
所以答案是肯定的。我想他是在说，没错，即便他们一直很忙，在太空中也绝对会感到无聊。勒罗伊告诉我一件我以前不知道的事。每天结束时，国际空间站上的所有活动都必须记录在案。每天，根据这个日志，计划都会发生改变。
Before you even launch aboard a six-month space mission, every minute of your mission has been planned out and taking into account all the requirements, constraints, priorities, things like that. And then you get up there, and you start the first day with day one. And at the end of your day, you've got logged on the computer the things that you finished, things that you got ahead on, things you maybe got behind on.
在你登上六个月的太空任务之前，任务的每一分钟都已经规划好了，并考虑到了所有的要求、限制、优先级等因素。然后你到了那里，从第一天开始执行。一天结束时，你在电脑上记录下你完成的事情、进度超前的事情，以及可能落后的事情。
And then while you sleep, the entire planning team on the ground in the mission control center is replanning the entire mission based on what happened that day and then ripple it all the way through to the end. And then they send up a new flight plan. And the next morning, when you get up, you've got a new flight plan on your computer because of this replanning team that has to do this every night.
然后当你睡觉时，地面任务控制中心的整个规划团队会根据当天发生的情况重新规划整个任务，并将其一直延伸到任务结束。然后他们会发送一个新的飞行计划上来。第二天早上当你起床时，由于这个每晚工作的重新规划团队，你的电脑上已经有了一个新的飞行计划。
I love that it fell to a whole crew of people at an entirely different location to plan, minute by minute, everything that a person should be doing with their hours. Eat breakfast and clean up between 0615 and 0645 hours. A 15-minute conference with mission control after experiments. Sleep for eight hours. Someone to check in, make sure you're on task.
我很喜欢这一点，那就是在另一个完全不同的地方，有一群人负责按分钟规划一个人每小时应该做的一切。06:15到06:45吃早餐并清理。实验后与任务控制中心进行15分钟的会议。睡八个小时。有人来确认，确保你在执行任务。
Unfortunately, unlike Leroy, I have no mission control. The usual order of my day has been disrupted since March. With no commute, my desk is now only a few feet away from my bed. My sleep schedule is messed up. A friend of mine said, we should stop calling it "working from home," but rather, "living at work."
不幸的是，和勒罗伊不同，我没有任务控制中心。自从三月以来，我日常生活的秩序被打乱了。没有了通勤，我的书桌距离我的床只有几英尺。我的睡眠时间乱了套。一位朋友说，我们不应该再把它叫“在家工作”，而应该叫“住在工作的地方”。
Everything feels like it's drifting-- and not just in my apartment. It'd be nice if someone seemed to have a bit of a plan, globally speaking.
一切感觉都在漂流——不仅仅是在我的公寓里。如果全球范围内有人能制定出一个计划，那该多好。
When Leroy and I first spoke, it was April. And at that point, I'd been alone indoors for about six weeks. I remember it as a slightly feral time. I joked that I wished I'd thought to trap a boyfriend before the pandemic hit, some kind of human space junk to occasionally bump into in my apartment. But then Leroy told me about the perils of cohabiting in space.
当勒罗伊和我第一次交谈时是在四月。那时，我已经独自待在室内大约六周了。我记得那是一段稍微有些野性的时期。我开玩笑说，真希望在疫情爆发前抓个男朋友，某种人类太空垃圾，偶尔能在我的公寓里碰个面。但随后勒罗伊告诉了我太空中共同生活的危险。
I talked to some of the cosmonauts who had been around for a long time. And they said, some crews came back, and they said, if I had had a weapon, if I had had a gun, I would have killed my crewmate. I mean, that's how bad it can get.
我和一些在太空中待了很长时间的宇航员聊过。他们说，有些机组人员回来后说，如果我当时有一件武器，如果我有一把枪，我肯定杀了我的同事。我是说，情况可能会变得有多糟。
I have no tension with my houseplants. My candles burn, but not with any malice. And I actually really like living alone. It's not that I want to fight with anyone. I just wish I had the option sometimes-- you know, break glass in case of boredom.
我和我的盆栽之间没有紧张关系。我的蜡烛在燃烧，但没有恶意。而且我实际上非常喜欢独处。并不是说我想和任何人吵架。我只是希望有时能有选择权——你知道，紧急情况下打破玻璃的那种无聊。
Leroy's longest stint in space came when he lived on the International Space Station with only one other person-- Salizhan Sharipov, a Kyrgyzstani cosmonaut-- for 192 days. For context, my personal expedition is currently around 130 days.
勒罗伊在太空中待的时间最长的一次是与另一个人——吉尔吉斯斯坦宇航员萨利赞·沙里波夫——一起在国际空间站生活了192天。作为对比，我个人的“探险”目前大约是130天。
Part of the terror of being alone right now is that this pandemic feels endless. I asked Leroy when things began to feel really impossible for him. Was there a time in space when the itch to be home became unbearable?
现在独处带来的部分恐惧感在于，这场疫情感觉没完没了。我问勒罗伊，他什么时候开始感到一切真的变得无法忍受。在太空中，是否有那么一段时间，对回家的渴望变得无法抑制？
I would say right around the four-month point. Three, four months seems to be kind of the right amount of time, if you ask most astronauts. And that's when you're saying, well, this is great. This is interesting. It's fulfilling, but I sure wouldn't mind going home either.
我会说大约在四个月的时候。如果你问大多数宇航员，三、四个月似乎是一个临界点。那时候你会说，嗯，这很棒。这很有趣。它很充实，但我绝对也不介意回家。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And when you start getting eager to go home is actually after the next crew arrives. You have generally about a week or a week and a half together before you go home. And so the next crew arrives, and you start getting really excited about going home. And that's when the time seems to slow to a crawl, [LAUGHS] that last week or so.
而当你开始渴望回家的时候，实际上是在下一批机组人员抵达之后。通常在回家前，你们在一起大约有一周到一周半的时间。所以下一批机组人员抵达，你开始对回家感到非常兴奋。而那正是时间似乎慢得像爬行一样的时候，[笑]那最后的一周左右。
That makes sense to me. Even in the majesty of space, four months is still four months. Four months of being alone, of being so far away-- it's hard. And four months is where we're at in this new reality. We're ready to come back to Earth, but we don't know when we'll be allowed to go home. There's still no cure, no vaccine, and a steady increase in new cases.
这对我来说很有意义。即使是在壮丽的太空中，四个月依然是四个月。四个月的孤独，远离家园——这很难。而这就是我们现在所处的新现实。我们准备好回到地球，但不知道什么时候才能被允许回家。目前仍然没有特效药，没有疫苗，新增病例还在稳步上升。
So what do we do? Today, we're going to hear from people who've had time to think about their aloneness, or their loneliness, even when they're in a crowd. How to be an astronaut or a solitary planet when there's a whole galaxy just around the corner. How to be alone. That's the feeling of today's program. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Bim Adewunmi. Stay with me.
那么我们该怎么办？今天，我们将听到一些花时间思考过他们的独处，或者孤独的人的故事，即使他们身处人群中。当银河系就在眼前时，如何成为一名宇航员或一颗孤独的行星。如何独处。这就是今天节目的主题。来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》。我是本·阿德温米。请继续收听。
Act One, The Unbearable Part. When isolation and social distancing was still new, I read a letter, and it felt like pages from a diary I hadn't even known I was writing. It was published in The Sewanee Review back in April. The writer, Danielle Evans, alone in Baltimore, seemed to synthesize the feeling of aloneness and loss and fear that I hadn't yet been able to even articulate. Here's Danielle reading a version of that letter.
第一幕，无法忍受的部分。当隔离和社交距离尚属新鲜事时，我读了一封信，感觉就像是在读我自己甚至都不知道在写的日记。它发表在四月的《塞瓦尼评论》上。作者丹妮尔·埃文斯，当时独自在巴尔的摩，似乎概括了我尚未能表达出的那种孤独、失落和恐惧感。下面是丹妮尔读那封信的版本。
"Who was everyone's last real human touch?" a friend asked at a Zoom birthday party in late March. I said a name, but once everyone hung up, I thought again, not sure if I remembered correctly.
“大家最后一次真正的人类接触是什么时候？”三月下旬的一个Zoom生日派对上，一位朋友问道。我说了一个名字，但当大家都挂断后，我又想了一遍，不确定是否记对了。
I walked myself through that last real day of human contact-- the first week of March on the last day of AWP, an annual writer's conference. I had planned to fly to San Antonio a day and a half early to treat a friend who'd had a difficult year to a pre-conference spa day, but in the days leading up to the conference, fear of the virus spread. Thousands of people, including my friend, canceled their travel plans.
我回顾了那最后一天真正的人类接触——三月的第一周，AWP（年度作家会议）的最后一天。我原本计划提前一天半飞往圣安东尼奥，为一位度过艰难一年的朋友提供会议前的SPA日，但在会议开始前的几天，对病毒的恐惧蔓延开来。成千上万的人，包括我的朋友，取消了旅行计划。
I canceled the spa day out of prudence, but my flight was departing as scheduled, and I wouldn't get reimbursed if I didn't get on it. I decided to travel, anxiously, but I am anxious as a general condition. One way to live in the world when you have anxiety is to get used to pushing it aside when it gets in the way of being alive.
出于谨慎，我取消了SPA日，但我的航班仍按计划起飞，如果我不登机，就不会退款。我决定旅行，虽然很焦虑，但焦虑是我的一种常态。当你患有焦虑症时，活在这个世界上的方式之一，就是习惯在它阻碍生活时将其推到一边。
This is my best explanation for why I trusted the city and the airlines and the institutions who said it was still safe to travel, and ignored the warnings of friends who said what was coming. I thought quarantine was still an if, and weeks away if so. And I thought if loneliness was coming soon, I did not want to be alone any longer than necessary.
这就是我为何信任城市、航空公司和机构，相信旅行仍然安全，而忽略了朋友们关于即将发生之事的警告的最好解释。我以为隔离仍然是一个假设，即便真的发生，也是几周后的事。而且我想，如果孤独即将来临，我不想比必要时间更长地独处。
The conference was part hectic work trip, part carnival. On its final day, tired after two days packed with events and panels, I slept in and stayed in bed for hours after I woke. I finally made it as far as the hotel lobby, intending to grab lunch, but instead spotted a friend at the bar. We spent a few hours day drinking, having a meandering conversation about our novels and major life decisions.
这次会议既是忙乱的工作之旅，也是一场嘉年华。最后一天，在经历了连续两天满满的活动和小组讨论后，我感到疲惫不堪，醒来后又在床上躺了几个小时。我终于挪到了酒店大堂，打算去吃午饭，结果在吧台发现了一个朋友。我们花了几小时白天喝酒，漫无目的地聊着我们的小说和重大的生活决定。
"I feel so settled," I said, believing it. The serendipity of the afternoon bled into the evening. I spent the day moving from crowded space to crowded space, running into friends, making plans for later in the night, or the month, or the year.
“我感到很安定，”我说，并且深信不疑。下午的意外之喜一直延续到晚上。我整天在拥挤的空间之间穿梭，遇见朋友，制定着当晚、或者当月、或者当年的计划。
Late in the evening, a group of us headed to the conference's dance party. But when we all went upstairs, the dance floor was hilariously, heartbreakingly empty. It already felt like a metaphor. Downstairs, people began to peel off. We were tired. Flights were early. It was starting to be unavoidably clear that we were in the before of something terrible and on the wrong side of caution.
深夜，我们一行人前往会议的舞会。但当我们上楼时，舞池出奇地、令人心碎地空荡荡的。这已经感觉像是一种隐喻了。楼下，人们开始陆续离开。我们累了。飞机航班很早。不可避免地清楚感觉到，我们正处于某种可怕事物的之前，正处于谨慎的错误一边。
I remember who was there. I remember that some people were already conscientiously not hugging or touching, that some people were there who I didn't know well enough to hug. Who was the last person who leaned into me to say goodbye? Who was the last person, besides me, to realize the party was over?
我记得谁在那儿。我记得有些人已经自觉地不拥抱或接触了，有些人是我不够熟到可以拥抱的。谁是最后一个向我倾身道别的人？谁是除了我之外，最后一个意识到派对结束的人？
Two days after I returned to Baltimore, the campus where I teach was closed immediately and indefinitely. I prepared myself for the city to shut down for about a month. I walked a block to buy extra cat food, and then a block more to stock up on canned and dried goods and, for reasons unclear to me, essential oils, at my tiny and mysterious neighborhood health food store. I reinstated the service that mailed me a box of fresh vegetables weekly.
我回到巴尔的摩两天后，我任教的校园立即且无限期地关闭了。我准备好迎接城市关闭大约一个月。我走了一个街区去买多余的猫粮，然后又走了一个街区去囤积罐头和干货，还有出于我不明原因购买的精油，在邻里那家微小而神秘的健康食品店。我恢复了每周给我邮寄一箱新鲜蔬菜的服务。
A month passed. The virus hadn't peaked yet. April and May passed. I kept waiting for a clear sign that the worst was over, but instead felt like we were all trapped in the opening half of a horror movie. By the time the city's stay-at-home order lifted in early June, little seemed to have changed to make me feel better about being in crowds, or riding the city bus, or sharing indoor space with people.
一个月过去了。病毒还没有达到顶峰。四月和五月过去了。我一直等待一个明确的信号，表明最坏的情况已经过去，却反而感觉我们都被困在了一部恐怖电影的开场部分。当六月初城市的居家令解除时，似乎几乎没有什么变化能让我对处于人群中、乘坐城市公交车或在室内与人共享空间感到好受些。
It's July now, and most weeks, I only go as far as my apartment building's front entryway to collect mail and occasional groceries and bring them inside to disinfect. In more exciting weeks, I venture down the fire escape to take out the recycling and walk around the block to come back in through my front door. Though, for three weeks, our recycling was on hold because of an outbreak at the Bureau of Solid Waste, and I stopped making even that small trip.
现在是七月，大多数周里，我只走到公寓楼的前厅拿邮件和偶尔的杂货，带进屋里消毒。在更令人兴奋的周里，我会冒险从防火梯下去处理回收垃圾，然后在街区转一圈，再从前门回来。不过，有三周时间，因为固体废物局爆发了疫情，我们的回收处理暂停了，我连那一小段路都不再走了。
In over three months, I have seen six delivery people, two neighbors in the hallway, one friend making a masked front door grocery drop-off, one repairman, one stranger who needed to tour the property, and my landlord.
在三个多月的时间里，我只见过六个送货员，两个走廊里的邻居，一个戴口罩到门口送杂货的朋友，一个修理工，一个需要参观房产的陌生人，还有我的房东。
As time passes, there are fewer unbearable days, but they are worse when they come. I had a running joke for years about how none of my survival skills would be useful in an apocalypse. But it turns out, being anxious and alone in my apartment, weighing which things I love are worth the possibility that they might hurt me, is the one scenario I was somewhat prepared for.
随着时间的推移，无法忍受的日子变少了，但当它们来临时却更糟糕。多年来我一直拿自己开玩笑，说我的任何生存技能在天启中都派不上用场。但事实证明，在公寓里焦虑而孤独地坐着，衡量我所热爱的事物是否值得冒可能伤害我的风险，正是我多少有些准备的情况。
At the start of the year, I had been looking forward to spending some time alone. I was on teaching leave for the spring semester and I thought it would be a luxury to be mostly at home for a while. I love my apartment. I bought myself a smart bike and taught myself to like it, anticipating a season when I would become a creature of odd habits and hours, and wouldn't want to walk to the gym after dark or in the spring rain. I was preparing to hibernate and not miss much.
年初时，我一直期待着花点时间独处。我春季学期在休假，以为有一段时间大部分时间待在家里会是一种奢侈。我喜欢我的公寓。我给自己买了一辆智能自行车，并强迫自己喜欢上它，预料到一个季节，我会成为一个拥有古怪习惯和作息的生物，不想在天黑后或春雨中走路去健身房。我准备好冬眠，不会错过太多东西。
Now I miss so many things. I take vitamin D pills and sometimes hover over the fire escape ledge, standing beside the trash can, to try to get some sunlight, and imagine the luxury of having a backyard. I miss my father, who is a 40-minute train ride away. The train feels out of the question. And I can't ask my father, working full time from home and recovering from minor surgery, to drive an hour each way just to visit.
现在我想念很多事情。我吃维生素D药片，有时站在垃圾桶旁的防火梯边缘徘徊，试着晒晒太阳，想象拥有一片后院的奢侈。我想念我的父亲，他坐火车40分钟就能到。火车感觉是不可能的选项。我不能让还要全职在家工作且刚从微创手术中恢复的父亲，为了探望我单程开车一小时。
I never learned to drive, something I sometimes considered a badge of city-dwelling honor. Earlier in the year, I told a relative I didn't need to learn to drive in Baltimore, when I live a short walk from Penn Station, and at least a dozen city buses stop within a block of my apartment. If I had a car and a license, I think now, I could drive to wave at my father from a safe distance.
我从没学会开车，这有时被我视为城市居住者的荣誉勋章。年初时，我告诉一位亲戚，在巴尔的摩不需要学开车，因为我离宾州车站只有几分钟路程，而且十几个城市公交车停靠站就在我公寓一个街区内。如果我有车和驾照，我想现在，我就能开车过去，在安全的距离外向父亲挥手致意。
When the casual relationship I had drifted into early in the year just as casually evaporated, I told a friend, I guess we weren't that serious about it, so it's for the best. Now the scolding voice in my head tells me that a person who believed in chasing after things, who didn't think it was as clear as people either want to be around you or they don't, and if you didn't know which, there was your answer-- well, that person might not be alone in her apartment for months.
当年初那种漫不经心的关系同样漫不经心地蒸发时，我告诉一个朋友，我想我们并不是那么认真，所以这样也好。现在我脑海中那个责备的声音告诉我，一个相信去追逐事物的人，一个不认为这就像“人们要么想和你在一起，要么不想，如果你不知道是哪种，答案就在那里”的人——好吧，那样的人可能不会在公寓里独处数月。
When I turned 35 a few years ago, I promised myself I'd let go of the idea that someday I was going to become a different kind of adult. I let myself accept that there would be no house or a husband or a baby or sudden mature renunciation of glitter.
几年前我35岁时，我答应自己要放下“总有一天我会成为另一种成年人”的想法。我让自己接受，不会有什么房子、丈夫、孩子，也不会突然成熟地摒弃亮片。
It was only the baby I really grieved, but I let myself have that grief and move on. I gave myself permission to live a life that wasn't waiting for my real life to start, to free all of my intimate relationships from the emotional tyranny of a ticking biological clock, to claim as a choice what would otherwise feel like it had happened to me.
只有孩子是我真正哀悼的，但我让自己拥有了那种悲伤，然后继续前进。我给了自己许可，去过一种不只是在等待真正生活开始的生活，去将我所有的亲密关系从生物钟滴答作响的情感暴政中解放出来，去声称那些本来会让我感觉是“发生在我身上”的事情是我的一种选择。
I thought it worked. But the loneliness of isolation some days mocks all of that, makes all of my possible joys feel ephemeral. I asked which of the things I promised myself I could still have-- casual flings, travel, community in the form of classrooms and bookstores and coffee shops and bars-- will survive this or exist in recognizable form when we emerge. It is possible to feel stuck with your choices even without wishing you'd made any differently.
我以为这奏效了。但隔离带来的孤独感有时会嘲笑这一切，让所有可能的快乐都变得短暂。我问自己，那些我承诺可以依然拥有的东西——随意的恋情、旅行、以教室、书店、咖啡店和酒吧形式存在的社区——有哪些能在这次疫情中幸存，或者在我们走出家门时以可辨认的形式存在。即使你不希望自己做出任何不同的选择，你也有可能感觉到被自己的选择困住了。
When I hear that this could go on for a year, I think it is lack of human touch, human contact, that will break me. And then I think it might actually be grief. Without the constant, busy buzz of my normal life, it's harder not to dwell on what is absent-- the lives I might have had, the life I would have if my mother was still alive.
当我听说这种情况可能会持续一年时，我想是缺乏人类的触碰、人类的接触会击垮我。然后我想，那实际上可能是悲伤。没有了我正常生活那持续、忙碌的嗡嗡声，我更难不去想那些缺席的事物——我本可能拥有的生活，如果我母亲还活着我本会有的生活。
I keep waiting for the first feeling I have that is wholly untouched by grief, or that is at least its own fresh grief, not marked by her death three years ago. But it hasn't come yet.
我一直在等待我拥有的第一种完全不受悲伤影响的感觉，或者至少是它自己全新的悲伤，而不是带上她三年前去世的印记。但这种感觉还没有到来。
When I heard the early descriptions of the virus, of what it does to people's breathing, I thought of my mother at the beginning of her illness, when she went to the ER with undiagnosed stage four cancer and a liter and a half of fluid in her lungs, and the doctor was planning to send her home with a laxative, until my mother's friend, a cardiologist at the same hospital, insisted they give her a CAT scan.
当我听到对这种病毒的早期描述，关于它对人们呼吸系统影响时，我想到了我母亲患病初期，她带着未确诊的四期癌症和肺部一升半的积液去了急诊室，医生计划让她带着泻药回家，直到我母亲的朋友，同一家医院的一位心脏病专家坚持要给母亲做CT扫描。
I thought of my mother at the end, when everything they had given her to keep the pain at bay, to keep her unnaturally calm while her body's every instinct told her to panic, also meant she couldn't hold her head up to cough or vomit. How many times she'd said she didn't want to die hooked up to tubes, so when they first asked to intubate her, her partner said no.
我想到母亲最后时刻，当他们给她的所有缓解疼痛、让她在身体每个本能都在尖叫着恐慌时保持非自然平静的药物，也意味着她无法抬头咳嗽或呕吐。她多少次说她不想插着管子死去，所以当他们第一次要求给她插管时，她的伴侣拒绝了。
How when I was alone with her later that day, she began to choke, suddenly awake and terrified. And I held her hand and I pushed the call button and knew we didn't have that much time, so I ran into the hallway screaming for help, and the nurse came running.
当那天晚些时候我独自与她在一起时，她开始窒息，突然醒来，惊恐万分。我握着她的手，按了呼叫铃，知道我们没多少时间了，所以我冲进走廊尖叫着求救，护士跑了过来。
I stood in that hallway, terrified my mother was going to die, while I was, in fact, at the hospital by her bedside, waiting for my mother to die, just not like that. How I didn't know for certain, until after they'd put the tube in, that I'd heard her voice for the last time.
我站在走廊里，惊恐地以为母亲要死了，而实际上我正陪在医院她的床边，等着母亲死去，只是不是以那种方式。我是如何不知道，直到他们插上管子后，我才确信我最后一次听到了她的声音。
In the first months of quarantine, sometimes in the middle of the day, I would find myself sobbing and only realize later why, which bit of news triggered which memory-- the descriptions of what the virus does to the body, how many of the early faces of the dead were Black women my mother's age, or the infuriating financial politics of our health care system. It was hard for me to untangle on a personal or national level the difference between a health crisis and the financial crisis.
在隔离的最初几个月，有时在白天，我会发现自己啜泣，后来才意识到为什么，哪条新闻触发了哪段记忆——关于病毒对身体作用的描述，关于早期死亡者中有多少是和我母亲同龄的黑人女性，或者是我们医疗体系中令人愤怒的金融政治。对我来说，在个人或国家层面梳理健康危机与金融危机之间的区别是很难的。
When my mother's CAT scan came back indicating a problem, before I could comfort her, I had to ask her for her insurance card and step out in the hallway to call in a payment, because I knew if she got any further behind, she would be uninsured.
当我母亲的CT扫描结果显示有问题时，在安慰她之前，我必须问她要保险卡，并走出走廊拨打支付电话，因为我知道如果她再落后一点，她就会失去保险。
I knew that because we'd fought the week before when she told me she had stopped paying her insurance. She said, "The only thing wrong with me is high blood pressure, and the only reason for that is stress. And the main reason I'm stressed is money." I said, "If there's something else wrong, by the time you know it, it will be too late." It was already too late.
我知道这一点是因为前一周我们吵过架，当时她告诉我她停止支付保险了。她说：“我唯一的问题就是高血压，而这唯一的理由就是压力。而我感到压力的主要原因就是钱。”我说：“如果还有别的问题，等你发现时，一切就太晚了。”当时确实已经太晚了。
When the virus first hit, I thought of what hell it would have been for my sick mother, after years of chemo and complications, to have to add a pandemic to her list of dangers. I had the unbearable thought that it was a good thing she didn't have to live through this.
当病毒第一次袭来时，我想象对于我那患病的母亲来说，在经过多年的化疗和并发症之后，还要在她的危险清单上增加一场大流行病，那该是何等的地狱。我产生了一个无法忍受的想法，那就是她不用经历这些真是一件好事。
As time passed, I thought more of my mother when she was well-- my mother, who would have made it maybe two weeks before calling to tell me she was coming to get me or she was coming to stay, but she wasn't letting me stay in my apartment alone for months. "But it's my apartment," I would have said. And she would have scoffed at my boundaries and come anyway.
随着时间的推移，我更多地想起了母亲身体健康的时候——我的母亲，她大概会坚持不到两周就会打电话告诉我，她要来接我，或者她要来住，她不会让我独自在公寓里待上几个月。“但这是我的公寓，”我会说。而她会对我划定的界限嗤之以鼻，然后无论如何都会来。
What I've been feeling acutely is the particular absence of the only person in the world who would have refused to leave me alone, even when I absolutely wanted to be. When I can step out of my personal grief for long enough, I summon my mother's tenacity in the face of the more collective grief. When the data on race began to come in, it was not a surprise, but it was devastating, and also terrifying.
我强烈感受到的是世界上唯一一个即使我绝对想独处也拒绝让我一个人待着的人的特殊缺失。当我能暂时跳出个人悲伤时，我会在集体悲伤面前唤起母亲的坚韧。当关于种族的数据开始出现时，这并不令人惊讶，但却是毁灭性的，而且令人恐惧。
When I saw who was dying and I heard the narrative shift to personal responsibility, I lost all faith that we would take this seriously enough for long enough. I knew my country, I thought.
当我看到谁在死去，听到叙事转向个人责任时，我对我们会足够认真对待这件事足够长的时间失去了所有信心。我想，我了解我的国家。
And I was afraid that once it thought this was a Black and brown problem, it would not blink at sacrificing gig workers and shipping plant workers and service workers and food workers and city employees to have back the world of money and parties. It would kill them and replace them for as long as it needed to, even once the color of the faces started to change.
而且我害怕，一旦它认为这是一个黑人和棕色人种的问题，它就不会在牺牲零工经济者、运输工厂工人、服务人员、食品工人和城市雇员以换回金钱和派对的世界时眨一下眼睛。只要需要，它就会杀死他们并替换他们，即使是肤色开始改变之后。
For months, I felt like my fear that Black life wasn't worth much in this country was another form of aloneness, which is why the shock of June's protests and the deaths that made them necessary felt like horror and hope at once, like we could say what had clearly been true all along, even if we couldn't yet say for certain that it would change.
几个月来，我觉得我对“黑人的生命在这个国家不值钱”的恐惧是另一种孤独，这就是为什么六月抗议活动的冲击和使之必要的死亡同时带给我恐惧和希望，就像我们可以说出一直以来都很明显是真的事情，即使我们还不能肯定地说它会改变。
Still, I'm terrified of getting sick. Because being sick alone means it may be too late when I realize how sick I am. I am terrified of having to go to the hospital alone because everything I know says there is no point in going to the hospital if I'm not well enough to credential myself.
尽管如此，我还是很害怕生病。因为独自生病意味着当我意识到自己病得有多重时，可能已经太晚了。我害怕不得不独自去医院，因为我所知道的一切都告诉我，如果我没有足够的能力为自己担保，去医院就毫无意义。
I do not have any particular health risk factors for this virus, except that I find doctors stressful, and my blood pressure spikes at the beginning of any doctor's visit. If the doctor is willing to humor me and take it again, my blood pressure is almost always normal and the file says I have anxiety. If the doctor is not or the visit was upsetting, then the file says my blood pressure is elevated, mild hypertension.
我没有任何针对这种病毒的特殊健康风险因素，只是我发现医生让人压力很大，而且每次去看医生时我的血压都会飙升。如果医生愿意迁就我再测一次，我的血压几乎总是正常的，档案上会写着我有焦虑症。如果医生不愿意，或者那次就诊很糟糕，档案上就会写着血压升高，轻度高血压。
If I got sick, no one would say she is a professor who just achieved a Peloton milestone and has a refrigerator full of almond milk and fresh vegetables and a book out soon. And she Clorox-wiped the apartment's front doors every time she went to get the mail.
如果我病了，没有人会说她是一名刚刚取得Peloton里程碑成就、冰箱里装满杏仁奶和新鲜蔬菜、很快有一本书问世的教授。而且她每次去拿邮件都会用高乐氏湿巾擦拭公寓前门。
Someone would say hypertension. Someone would say comorbidity. Someone would read the summarized statistics and say, that one doesn't count. She was basically dead anyway. Because this is the game we are playing with language, one where I and most of the people in my family cannot count as dying of this because we are already not alive.
有人会说高血压。有人会说合并症。有人会读着总结的数据说，那个不算。她本来就差不多死了。因为这是我们用语言玩的游戏，一个让我和我家人中的大多数人因为已经“不存在”而不能算作死于此的游戏。
When I think this, it is not especially good for my blood pressure. I add spite to my reasons to stay alive and well. I greet my anxiety like an old friend, one who wants me to live a long life and forgives me when I doubt her.
当我想到这一点时，这对我的血压尤其不好。我给我的生存理由又增加了一份恶意。我像老朋友一样问候我的焦虑，那个希望我长寿并在我怀疑她时原谅我的朋友。
I alternate between my peppy smart bike and the despair of Twitter. I order new books from local bookstores before I've finished the last batch. I donate what I can where I can, work my way through the local tip jar Venmo, looking for my bartenders and baristas and my hairdresser.
我在活泼的智能自行车和推特的绝望之间切换。我在完成上一批书之前就从当地书店订购新书。我尽我所能进行捐赠，通过本地的小费罐Venmo，寻找我的酒保、咖啡师和理发师。
I talk to my father several times a week. In recent years, he has taken to beekeeping in a county park near his house. And he is pleased that he can tend to his hives without violating social distancing guidelines. I am anxious to find a safe way to visit him. I confess I am indifferent to visiting the bees.
我每周与父亲通话几次。近年来，他在家附近的一个县立公园开始养蜂。他很高兴自己可以在不违反社交距离准则的情况下照看蜂箱。我急于寻找一种安全的方式去探望他。我承认我对参观蜜蜂没什么兴趣。
I congratulate my students on their accomplishments. I read a friend's daughter books via Zoom and come away with a critical thesis on reforms needed in pixie society.
我祝贺我的学生取得成就。我通过Zoom给朋友的女儿读书，并得出了关于精灵社会需要改革的批判性论文。
My most cautious friends in the city haven't socialized in person in months either. I regard with affection and suspicion the invitations I do get for masked socially distanced gatherings as our restrictions relax. I am a lot of people's good friend and no one's singular person. And so every time someone reaches out, I think, yes, I would love to see you. And no, I cannot risk it if your social circle is already wide enough that I am included.
我城里最谨慎的朋友几个月来也没有亲自社交。随着限制措施的放松，我带着好感和怀疑对待我收到的参加戴口罩的社交距离聚会的邀请。我是许多人的好朋友，却不是任何人的唯一。所以每次有人伸出援手，我想，是的，我很想见你。不，如果你的社交圈已经广到我被包括在内，我无法冒险。
I'm trying to imagine the first day I will say yes. I'm trying to imagine when I can hug someone again, and beyond that, to the first day I will take touch for granted, to the next time I will go someplace and spend the day among friends again and leave not remembering which of the people I adore I said goodbye to last, not conscious of the significance, not conscious of the danger.
我试着想象我说“好”的第一天。我试着想象什么时候才能再次拥抱某人，并在此之后，想象我第一次将触碰视为理所当然的那一天，想象下一次我会去某个地方，再次在朋友中度过一天，离开时不再记得我最后和哪位我钟爱的人道别，不再意识到这种意义，不再意识到危险。
Danielle Evans is the author of a short story collection called Before You Suffocate Your Own Fool Self.
丹妮尔·埃文斯是短篇小说集《在你窒息自己的傻瓜行为之前》的作者。
Act Two, A Notion Apart. There's a way that loneliness calls to loneliness. The more you know it, the more likely you are to see it in the world. Lonely people can see things that other non-lonely people might have missed. Lilly Sullivan has a story about that. It takes place in a vast non-human setting-- literally, no humans. Here's Lilly.
第二幕，一个分开的念头。有一种孤独呼唤孤独的方式。你了解得越多，就越有可能在世界上看到它。孤独的人可以看到其他不孤独的人可能错过的事物。莉莉·沙利文有一个关于这方面的故事。它发生在一个广阔的非人类环境里——字面上，没有人类。下面是莉莉。
So, seven years ago, when I was just starting out in radio, I did a story about this scientific discovery, because there was something about it that I wanted to understand. The guy who first noticed this thing was named Joe George, on an island off the coast of Washington State.
七年前，当我刚开始做广播时，我做了一个关于这个科学发现的故事，因为其中有一些我想理解的东西。第一个注意到这一点的人名叫乔·乔治，在华盛顿州海岸外的一个岛上。
Yeah, so I was in the Navy. And we looked for submarines and that in the open ocean.
是的，我当时在海军。我们在公海寻找潜艇之类的东西。
And by looking, they were really listening. This was the '80s, by the way. And the Navy had these devices called hydrophones that would listen to sounds in the ocean, anything that might be a Soviet sub. Joe had been doing it for decades-- could basically identify any ocean sound by its wiggles on the chart.
通过“寻找”，他们实际上是在“倾听”。顺便提一下，那是80年代。海军有一种叫水听器的装置，可以监听海洋中的声音，任何可能是苏联潜艇的东西。乔已经做了几十年——基本上可以通过图表上的曲线识别任何海洋声音。
But one day, he saw something he'd never seen before. A marine biologist looked at the signal, said that it might be a whale. It seemed like it was huge, like a blue whale or a fin whale, judging by the characteristics of its call. But the song this whale was singing was totally off.
但有一天，他看到了从未见过的东西。一位海洋生物学家看了信号，说这可能是一头鲸鱼。从它的叫声特征判断，它看起来非常巨大，像蓝鲸或长须鲸。但这头鲸鱼唱的歌完全不对劲。
Because the whales we were looking at-- where it would be the loudest was down at 20 Hertz. And this one, he was at-- he started out at 52 Hertz.
因为我们正在观察的鲸鱼——声音最响亮的地方是在20赫兹。而这一个，他是在——他从52赫兹开始。
Meaning the sound was over an octave higher than it should be. And they could never detect any other whales with him. These kinds of whales are really social animals. They often traveled together in groups called pods.
这意味着声音比它应该有的频率高出了一个八度以上。而且他们从未探测到任何其他鲸鱼与他在一起。这类鲸鱼是非常社交的动物。它们通常结成称为“荚”的群体一起旅行。
And usually, when one whale calls out, other whales respond, calling back and forth to each other from miles away. Without that, they'd never be able to find each other in a huge space like the ocean. But this whale, when he called out, no whale ever seemed to respond.
通常，当一头鲸鱼呼唤时，其他鲸鱼会做出回应，在数英里外来回呼唤彼此。没有这一点，它们永远无法在像海洋这样巨大的空间里找到对方。但这头鲸鱼，当他呼唤时，似乎没有鲸鱼回应。
I'd always be looking for something else to see if there was anything out there like that. And through the years, it was the only vocalization like that in, I'll say, the North Pacific Ocean.
我总是会寻找别的东西，看看外面是否有类似的东西。多年来，我可以说，它是北太平洋中唯一那样的发声。
Hm.
嗯。
There was nobody else like it.
没有其他人像它一样。
I can actually play you a recording of the call they picked up back then. Huge whales like that, like fin whales or blue whales, they're among the loudest creatures on Earth. Their songs to each other rumble across the ocean. They can hear each other from 1,000 miles away.
实际上我可以为你播放一段他们当时采集到的录音。像这样的巨大鲸鱼，比如长须鲸或蓝鲸，它们是地球上最响亮的生物之一。它们彼此之间的歌声在海洋中回荡。它们能在1000英里外听到彼此。
But those same songs, they're at frequencies too low for most humans to hear. But this whale's call is high enough that most humans can actually hear it. Lots of speakers don't play sounds at such low frequencies, but see if you can hear him.
但同样的歌声，频率太低，大多数人类听不到。但这头鲸鱼的叫声足够高，大多数人类实际上可以听到。很多扬声器播放不出这种低频的声音，但看看你能不能听到他。
[WHALE CALL]
[鲸鱼叫声]
And if you couldn't hear that, here it is shifted up a bit to make it easier.
如果你听不到，这里把它调高了一些，更容易听见。
[WHALE CALL]
[鲸鱼叫声]
For scientists, they thought, this is so useful. Usually, it was almost impossible to track an individual whale because you pick up on their entire pods. But now they could follow a single whale's migration precisely.
对科学家来说，他们想，这太有用了。通常，追踪单独的一头鲸鱼几乎是不可能的，因为你会捕捉到它们整个群体的声音。但现在他们可以精确地跟踪一头鲸鱼的迁徙。
And as they tracked the whale like this, Joe realized the whale was in the wrong place, roaming miles away from where other whales were migrating, calling out all the time, never seeming to get a response.
当他们这样追踪鲸鱼时，乔意识到这头鲸鱼走错了地方，在远离其他鲸鱼迁徙路线的地方漫游，一直在呼唤，却似乎从未得到回应。
Word of this eventually made it out into the public. A science writer for The New York Times wrote a small story about it, "Song of the Sea, a Capella and Unanswered." When people heard about this, they thought, oh, my God, poor whale.
这件事最终传到了公众耳中。《纽约时报》的一位科学作家写了一篇关于它的小短文，“大海之歌，无伴奏且未得到回应。”当人们听到这个消息时，他们想，天哪，可怜的鲸鱼。
People wondered, maybe other whales couldn't hear him because of his song's high frequency. Or maybe he couldn't hear other whales. Or maybe he's a hybrid, maybe a cross between a fin and a blue. And because he sounds so strange, other whales are afraid of him, so they don't respond.
人们纳闷，也许其他鲸鱼因为他歌声的高频而听不到他。也许他听不到其他鲸鱼。或者也许他是一个杂交品种，可能是长须鲸和蓝鲸的混种。因为他听起来太奇怪了，其他鲸鱼害怕他，所以不回应。
When whales keep silent, that's how whales hide. There was just something about the idea of a creature moving through life constantly calling out to others and never getting a response. He seemed fundamentally out of sync in a way that got to people.
当鲸鱼保持沉默时，那就是鲸鱼躲藏的方式。一个生物在生命中不断呼唤同类却从未得到回应的想法，本身就有些东西。他似乎以一种让人触动的方式与世界脱节了。
I felt this way, too. I first heard about the whale five years before I talked to Joe. Back then, I spent a lot of time alone. I actually had a job where I traveled 24/7 for two years, barely seeing friends or family or anyone I knew.
我也曾有过这种感觉。在我和乔交谈的前五年，我就听说过这头鲸鱼。那时候，我花了很多时间独处。我当时有一份工作，我两年里24小时全天候旅行，几乎见不到朋友、家人或任何认识的人。
I would email myself passages I liked from books so I could read them over and over. Here's one of them. It's from a book by James Salter. He wrote, "In solitude, one must penetrate. One must endure. The icy beginning is where it is worst. One must pass all that. One must go forward all the way, through bitterness, through righteous feelings, advancing upon it like a holy city, sensing the true joy."
我会把书中我喜欢的段落发邮件给自己，这样我就能反复阅读。这里有一段。它来自詹姆斯·萨尔特的一本书。他写道：“在孤独中，人必须深入。人必须忍受。冰冷的开端是最糟糕的地方。人必须跨越这一切。人必须一直向前，穿过苦涩，穿过公正的感情，像向着圣城一样前进，感受真实的快乐。”
I still like that idea. Loneliness is a thing you can get better at, and that getting better at it would take you somewhere more true. I started to think of solitude as a project I wanted to master.
我仍然喜欢那个想法。孤独是一件你可以变得更擅长的事情，而变得擅长这件事会带你去向更真实的地方。我开始认为独处是我想要掌握的一个项目。
Over time, more and more people heard about this whale. I remember seeing someone post about it on Facebook. And within a day, 20,000 people wrote comments. There were the people who wanted to try to fix the whale.
随着时间推移，越来越多的人听说了这头鲸鱼。我记得看到有人在Facebook上发布关于它的消息。一天之内，就有2万人发表了评论。这些人想尝试“修复”这头鲸鱼。
One person asked, "Why can't we help it?" Another wrote, "Why can't it be tagged with something to rebroadcast the calls at a lower frequency?" The answer-- you just can't. People wrote music inspired by him, like this song.
有人问：“我们为什么不能帮它？”另一人写道：“为什么不能给它贴上某种能以更低频率转播叫声的标签？”答案是——你就是不能。人们创作了受他启发的音乐，比如这首歌。
[PIANO OF "THE LONELIEST CREATURE ON EARTH"]
[钢琴曲“地球上最孤独的生物”]
I talked to a guy in Ireland who was going through a divorce. His wife saw the story online and emailed him a link from where she was sitting in the next room. Another guy I talked to made mixtapes of the whale's song and would mail those tapes, actual cassettes, to strangers who asked him for it.
我和爱尔兰的一个正经历离婚的男人谈过。他妻子在网上看到了这个故事，从隔壁房间发了一个链接给他。我聊过的另一个人制作了这头鲸鱼歌声的混音带，并会把这些录音带——真正的盒式磁带——寄给向他索要的陌生人。
Someone in Germany wrote a children's book. People imagined his life in the icy depths, swimming 100 years alone. There we were, all of us walking around, dizzy in our own isolations, connecting to this whale, rather than to other people. Scientists called him 52 Hertz. The rest of us called him "the loneliest creature on Earth."
德国有人写了一本儿童读物。人们想象他在冰冷的深渊中，独自游了100年。我们就这样，所有人都在走动，在各自的隔绝中感到眩晕，与这头鲸鱼相连，而不是与其他人类相连。科学家称他为“52赫兹”。我们其他人称他为“地球上最孤独的生物”。
When I talked to Joe, he raised this issue that all those blogs kept overlooking and that I had overlooked, too. We have no idea if this whale's alone at all. Just because we can't hear other animals with him doesn't mean they're not there. He could be swimming with another group of whales or with a group of females, whose vocalizations don't travel as far.
当我与乔谈话时，他提出了所有那些博客一直忽略、我也忽略的问题。我们根本不知道这头鲸鱼是否孤独。仅仅因为我们听不到其他动物与他在一起，并不意味着它们不在那里。他可能正与另一群鲸鱼一起游泳，或者与一群发声传不了那么远的雌性鲸鱼一起。
There is, of course, one thing that could answer whether or not he's actually alone. We could go look at him. But actually, all these years, no one has ever seen him. All we have is an idea of him. He's just a sound in the ocean. Even Joe hasn't seen him. He's only heard his calls. Joe told me back then it'd be next to impossible to find him physically.
当然，有一件事可以回答他是否真的孤独。我们可以去看他。但实际上，所有这些年来，没人见过他。我们拥有的只是关于他的想法。他只是海洋中的一种声音。连乔都没见过他。他只听过他的叫声。乔当时告诉我，要物理上找到他简直是不可能的。
Right, no, we have no idea what he looks like. It'd be like looking for a needle in a haystack out there.
没错，不，我们不知道他长什么样。那就像是在那儿大海捞针。
Why?
为什么？
Because the ocean is big. And you're looking for one whale. You know, how big? Out in the ocean, it's not that big. Even in a square mile, it's hard to find stuff.
因为海洋很大。而你是在找一头鲸鱼。你知道，有多大？在海洋里，它没那么大。即使是在一平方英里内，找到东西也很难。
Listening back to this interview now, seven years after I recorded it, I can hear myself fishing, trying to see if there was any part of Joe that thought about him the way I did.
七年后回听这次采访，我能听到自己当时在“钓鱼”，试图看看乔身上是否有哪一部分像我一样思考它。
Has this-- I guess, this story for you, is it mostly pure science for you? Or do you think of this as personal as well?
这个——我猜，这个故事对你来说，主要是纯科学吗？还是你认为它也很私人？
For me, I look at it more science, discovery of a different whale.
对我来说，我看它更多是科学，是关于一种不同鲸鱼的发现。
Mhm.
嗯。
Yeah, more scientific.
是的，更科学。
More scientific.
更科学。
I can hear myself being disappointed here. I keep trying.
我能听到自己在这里表现出的失望。我一直试探。
Do you feel like you know the whale?
你觉得你了解这头鲸鱼吗？
Well, know it? Yeah, I know it a bit, but not fully.
嗯，了解它？是的，我了解一点，但不完全。
So have you ever been just mowing your lawn, and all of a sudden, maybe after you saw the blogs, did you ever have a thought, like, oh, maybe that is a little sad. Did you ever have a moment where you did think that it was-- the story was romantic in some way?
那你有没有在割草时，突然，也许在看到那些博客后，有过一个想法，比如，哦，也许那有点悲伤。你有没有过一个瞬间，你确实认为它——这个故事在某种程度上是浪漫的？
Hm. Hm. No? [LAUGHS] No. I'd have to say no.
嗯。嗯。没有？[笑]没有。我不得不说没有。
Joe told me, we have no idea if he's lonely. We don't even know if whales get lonely. We're all guessing here. And since all we can do is guess, here's another possibility.
乔告诉我，我们根本不知道他是否感到孤独。我们甚至不知道鲸鱼是否会感到孤独。我们在这里都是在猜测。既然我们所能做的只是猜测，这是另一种可能性。
Maybe he's hearing other whales and avoiding them. Maybe he wants to be alone. Or maybe he doesn't mind. I hope that's true. Me, I don't think about it much anymore. I stopped thinking about him after I got a dog.
也许他听到了其他鲸鱼的声音并在躲避它们。也许他想独处。或者也许他不介意。我希望那是真的。至于我，我不再多想了。我有了一只狗之后就不再想他了。
Lilly Sullivan is one of the producers of our show. She did her earlier story about the whale as part of the Transom Story Workshop.
莉莉·沙利文是我们节目的制作者之一。她关于鲸鱼的早期故事是作为Transom故事工作室的一部分制作的。
Coming up, a kid in Texas in isolation with his mom. He invents a game that's not exactly a game, that's a lot like real life. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，一个在德克萨斯州与母亲隔离的孩子。他发明了一个游戏，那不是一个真正的游戏，但非常像现实生活。稍后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Bim Adewunmi, in for Ira Glass. Our program today, How to Be Alone. Act Three, The Parent Trap.
这里是《美国生活》。我是本·阿德温米，代班艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目主题是“如何独处”。第三幕，父母陷阱。
So lots of people have been spending time isolated with just the few people in their family. This next story is about a more extreme version of that. It's about a mother and her son who really had no choice about it. They were at a family detention center in Dilley, Texas.
很多人一直在与家人中的少数几个人进行隔离。接下来的这个故事是关于这种情况下一个更极端的版本。它是关于一位母亲和她的儿子，他们真的对此没有选择。他们当时在德克萨斯州迪利的家庭拘留中心。
You probably remember, a couple of years ago, parents and children were being separated at the border. They also sometimes end up at places like this. There's three of them in the country. It's a particular kind of aloneness. You're in a group, but at the same time, being kept away from the rest of the world.
你可能还记得，几年前，父母和孩子在边境被拆散。他们有时也会最终被送到这样的地方。全国有三个这样的中心。这是一种特殊的孤独感。你身处群体中，但同时又被隔绝在世界之外。
A little while ago, this mom and her son were offered a way out, but there was a catch. One of our producers, Nadia Reiman, explains.
不久前，这位母亲和她的儿子获得了一个离开的机会，但有一个附带条件。我们的制作人之一，纳迪亚·雷曼，为我们解释。
When I asked the mom, who I'm calling Yiret, to describe the detention center to me, she said, "Can't you all just secretly fly a drone or something so you can see it?" She's a get-things-done kind of person. "You could attach a wire to a psychologist who comes in here and make recordings." She says she has ideas like this all the time.
当我请那位我称之为伊雷特的母亲向我描述拘留中心时，她说：“你们不能秘密地飞个无人机什么的，这样就能看到了吗？”她是一个实干型的人。“你可以把电线连到一个进来这里的心理学家身上，进行录音。”她说她总是会有这样的想法。
The Dilley family detention center is the biggest of its kind. It's a bunch of trailers, like the temporary housing kind arranged in clusters, surrounded by a chain-linked fence. There's a cafeteria and a gym area with arts and crafts supplies. It's all moms and kids.
迪利家庭拘留中心是同类中心中最大的一个。它是一堆拖车，就像那种安排成群的临时住房，被铁链围栏包围。有一个自助餐厅和一个有艺术和手工艺用品的健身区。全是母亲和孩子。
When Yiret and her son first got there, she talked constantly with the other moms, about which guards were nice and which were jerks, about the many ways the food could be better, about all the people they'd left behind. Her son, who I'm calling Alejandro, he's eight. He made up this game that he'd play all the time.
当伊雷特和她的儿子刚到那里时，她不断地和其他母亲交谈，关于哪个警卫人好，哪个是混蛋，关于食物怎么改善，关于他们留下来的所有人。她的儿子，我称他为亚历杭德罗，八岁。他编了一个游戏，经常玩。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
He would play pretend as if he was the judge. My goodness, he would come out with all the other kids, and he would sit down. And he would say, "I'm the judge."
他会假装自己是法官。天哪，他会和其他所有孩子一起出来，坐下。然后他会说，“我是法官。”
It was immigration court, of course. He'd never actually been there, but he pieced all of this together from stuff he'd heard.
当然，这是移民法庭。他实际上从没去过那里，但他从听到的事情中拼凑出了这一切。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
And then he'd tell one of the other kids that he was the officer and the other kid that he was the attorney. And he would ask the psychologist for lots of pieces of paper and for folders. I mean, I even participated. I would join in to prepare a written paper so that we could have the kids sign.
然后他会告诉其他孩子中的一个，他是官员，另一个孩子是律师。他会向心理学家要很多纸和文件夹。我是说，我甚至参与了。我会加入进去，准备一份书面文件，这样我们就可以让孩子们签名。
He was a pretty lenient judge. He'd give all the kids asylum most of the time.
他是个相当宽容的法官。大多数时候，他会给所有的孩子庇护权。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Sometimes when he would get mad, he'd tell them, I'm denying you asylum. That was the only time where they would be like that. They would be laughing. And it made me feel, like, a nostalgia, because of how my son was with how he was doing mentally.
有时当他生气时，他会告诉他们，我不给你们庇护。那是唯一他们会那样的时刻。他们会大笑。这让我感到一种怀旧，因为我儿子在心理上表现得如何。
Which was not great, especially after coronavirus got going. Alejandro wasn't allowed to roam around as much. He mostly had to stay inside the trailer with his mom. He'd pretend all the time that today was the day they were getting out, like he was trying to will it into existence. Have faith, he'd say. It will happen. And then, one morning, a guard came and woke them up.
表现并不好，尤其是在新冠疫情爆发后。亚历杭德罗不再被允许四处走动。他大部分时间必须和母亲待在拖车里。他总是假装今天就是他们出去的日子，好像他正试图用意志实现它。要有信心，他会说。这会发生的。然后，一天早上，一名警卫走来叫醒了他们。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
So I was sleepy because I tried to wake up my son later in the day so we wouldn't get up too early. So I kept him sleeping until 10:00 or 11:00 in the morning. That way, his day would be shorter and would go by faster. And I did things like that.
所以我很困，因为我试图晚点叫醒我儿子，这样我们就不会起得太早。所以我让他一直睡到上午10点或11点。那样的话，他的一天会更短，过得更快。我做了像那样的事情。
That day, they knocked on my door. And the officer told me, ma'am. She told me, they need you in court at 9:45. OK, I told the officer. And I was happy and I left the room. Happy because I said to myself, today, I'm getting out.
那天，他们敲了我的门。警卫告诉我，女士。她告诉我，他们在9点45分需要你去法庭。好的，我告诉警卫。我很开心，离开了房间。开心是因为我对自己说，今天，我要出去了。
She gets Alejandro and steps outside her trailer. She merely sees that all of the other moms are also outside with their kids. She's like, hey, I got called into court. And they're all like, me, too. Everyone had been summoned.
她带上亚历杭德罗走出拖车。她仅仅看到所有其他的母亲也带着孩子在外面。她说，嘿，我被传唤去法庭了。她们都说，我也是。每个人都被传唤了。
They go to this huge trailer that functions as a courthouse. And as soon as they walk in, they get sent to different courtrooms. There's like 10 of them per room-- no judge, no lawyers. Just a couple of ICE officers, Immigration and Customs Enforcement.
他们去了那个作为法庭的大拖车。他们一走进去，就被分到了不同的法庭。每个房间大约有10个人——没有法官，没有律师。只有几个ICE（移民和海关执法局）官员。
Yiret sat down and put Alejandro on her lap. Some of the other moms had their kids with them, too. An ICE officer began speaking to them. "We need a signature from you guys," she says the officer told them in Spanish. So that the kids can go with their sponsor, a relative or a responsible adult who could take care of them. In other words, her son could be released, but she would stay here, alone in detention.
伊雷特坐下，把亚历杭德罗放在膝盖上。一些其他的母亲也带着孩子。一名ICE官员开始对他们讲话。“我们需要你们签名，”她说官员用西班牙语告诉他们。这样孩子们就可以和担保人在一起，担保人是一名可以照顾他们的亲戚或负责任的成年人。换句话说，她的儿子可以被释放，但她将留在这里，独自在拘留中。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
He didn't say separate, but we're not dumb. And from the moment you're saying that you're talking about the kids staying and without me, obviously, it's a separation.
他没说“分开”，但我们不傻。从你说出这话的那一刻起，你谈论的就是孩子们留下来而没有我，这显然就是一种分离。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
While this is happening, Alejandro is sitting there, just absorbing it all. He doesn't say anything. The officer said they should sign because of the coronavirus. Their kids would be safer somewhere else, not locked up in here.
当这一切发生时，亚历杭德罗坐在那里，只是在吸收这一切。他什么也没说。官员说他们应该签名，因为新冠病毒。他们的孩子在别的地方会更安全，而不是被关在这里。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
So one of the moms got up and said, "Excuse me." She said, "How could you think that if this is dangerous for the kids, it's not dangerous for us, the coronavirus?"
所以其中一位母亲站起来说，“不好意思。”她说，“如果这对孩子很危险，你怎么认为这对我们——新冠病毒——不危险呢？”
There is COVID at Dilley. Some of the guards and some of the ICE officers have tested positive. The document the ICE officer handed Yiret to sign, it was in English. She asked for one in Spanish. They said no. She asked if she could take a copy and show her lawyer first. They said no. So she started to quietly freak out.
迪利有新冠病毒。一些警卫和一些ICE官员检测呈阳性。ICE官员递给伊雷特签名的文件是用英语写的。她要求一份西班牙语的。他们拒绝了。她问是否可以拿一份副本先给律师看。他们拒绝了。于是她开始悄悄地惊慌失措。
Then she notices another one of the moms, a lady that had been there for about a year and always seemed to know what to do. She gets up and goes to the bathroom. So Yiret is like, I got to talk to her. Yiret takes Alejandro's hand and tries to follow her, but a guard stops them. No one's allowed to go to the bathroom together-- social distancing.
然后她注意到另一位母亲，一位在那里待了一年左右、似乎总是知道该怎么做的女士。她起身去了洗手间。于是伊雷特想，我得跟她谈谈。伊雷特牵着亚历杭德罗的手试图跟上去，但一名警卫拦住了他们。不允许任何人一起去洗手间——社交距离。
Yiret's like, it's the boy. He has to use the bathroom. It works. Once they're in the bathroom, she picks the stall next to the old-timer, who tells her, don't sign. You don't know where the kids will actually end up.
伊雷特说，是孩子。他需要上厕所。这招管用。一旦他们进了洗手间，她选择了那位老手旁边的隔间，老手告诉她，不要签。你不知道孩子们最终会去哪里。
Yiret is supposed to go back to the room at this point. But she doesn't. She improvises an escape. She and Alejandro start to leave the trailer. And when the guard asks, where are you going, she says, "We signed. We're done." Then she and Alejandro run to another trailer. Where she can call a lawyer, which she does.
此时伊雷特应该回到房间。但她没有。她即兴想出了一个逃跑计划。她和亚历杭德罗开始离开拖车。当警卫问，你要去哪里时，她说，“我们签了。我们做完了。”然后她和亚历杭德罗跑到另一辆拖车。在那里她可以给律师打电话，她确实这么做了。
Her voice is really distinct, so I was like, is this Yiret? And she was like, yes. She was talking really fast, and she sounded really worried and confused and had a lot of questions.
她的声音非常独特，所以我心想，是伊雷特吗？她说，是的。她说话很快，听起来非常担心和困惑，有很多问题。
This is Ixchel Lopez. She's a paralegal for Proyecto Dilley. It's a group that offers pro bono representation for families in detention. Normally, there's always a team of them just sitting in a room at Dilley. But since COVID, they've had to work remotely. So they came up with a way to still be there. They made a hotline and took turns answering calls coming from the detention center. That day was Ixchel's day.
这是伊克塞尔·洛佩兹。她是迪利项目的律师助理。这是一个为被拘留家庭提供公益代理的团体。通常，总有一个团队坐在迪利的一个房间里。但自疫情以来，他们不得不远程工作。所以他们想出了一种依然可以出现在那里的方法。他们设了一条热线，轮流接听来自拘留中心的电话。那天是伊克塞尔的日子。
Did it surprise you, in a way, that she was the first to call? Or were you kind of like, of course she'd be the first to call?
在某种程度上，她第一个打电话让你惊讶吗？还是你觉得，当然她会是第一个打来的？
Literally, I was like, of course. Of course. Like, that was entirely unsurprising. I was like, out of everyone, it would be her. Like, she's so badass. And she's so just, like, strong-willed, and she says it as it is. She's like, this is messed up.
真的，我当时想，当然。当然。就像，这完全不出人意料。我想，在所有人中，一定是她。就像，她太硬核了。她只是那么……意志坚定，有一说一。她说，这太扯淡了。
I think as soon as she said, OK, they're asking us if we want our children to be sent to live with our sponsors, I was like, oh my God. Like, they're going to separate families again. And I remember hanging up with her and cussing up a storm and being like, what the fuck? Like, what?
我想当她说“好的，他们在问我们是否希望孩子被送到担保人那里居住”时，我就想，噢，我的天。他们又要分开家庭了。我记得挂了电话后骂了一通，心想，这到底是什么鬼？
Ixchel starts texting, messaging, e-mailing what's going on to the rest of her team.
伊克塞尔开始向她的团队发送信息，说明正在发生什么。
I think I hung up the phone and immediately got another call from--
我想我挂了电话，立刻又接到了另一个电话，来自——
Oh, really?
噢，真的吗？
Yeah, maybe within, like, two or three minutes.
是的，可能在两三分钟内。
It was another mom from Dilley. Frantic calls were also coming in to lawyers from the other two detention centers, all telling the same general story. ICE was asking families to sign something. But the whole thing was really confusing. Some people were saying that they weren't even shown a document. Some were told, sign this. It just proves we talked to you.
那是来自迪利的另一位母亲。疯狂的电话也打到了其他两个拘留中心的律师那里，都在讲述同一个大概的故事。ICE要求家庭签署某些东西。但整个事情非常令人困惑。有些人说他们甚至没被出示文件。有些人被告知，签这个。这只是证明我们和你谈过了。
But others say ICE was threatening them, telling them that they had to sign, no choice. That the officer asked if they would give their child up for adoption. In many cases, the officers asked all of this in front of the kids.
但其他人说ICE在威胁他们，告诉他们必须签名，没得选。官员问他们是否愿意把孩子送去领养。在许多情况下，官员是在孩子面前问这一切的。
Within 24 hours, the lawyers from all three family detention centers got on a giant Zoom call with press to sound the alarm, arguing it was illegal to break up families like this by asking parents to sign something they couldn't even understand. And ICE wouldn't give the lawyers a copy of the document. ICE did put out a statement shortly after this, saying the officers were just going over a routine form with the detainees.
24小时内，所有三个家庭拘留中心的律师在Zoom上召开了一次巨大的会议，与媒体一起发出警报，争辩说要求父母签署他们甚至无法理解的东西来拆散家庭是违法的。而ICE拒绝给律师提供文件副本。ICE在此后不久发表了一份声明，称官员只是在和被拘留者过一份常规表格。
When Yiret hangs up with Ixchel, she looks over at her son, who's been quiet this whole time.
当伊雷特挂断伊克塞尔的电话时，她看向她的儿子，他这一整天都很安静。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
His little eyes were filled with tears. He was worried since he thought that he was going to be separated from me. And he told me, "Don't sign. Because wherever you go, I go."
他的小眼睛里充满了泪水。他很担心，因为他以为他要和我分开了。他告诉我，“别签。因为你去哪儿，我就去哪儿。”
While Yiret was making the phone call, the guards had started looking for her. They put her name and photo up on the screens that are all around the facility. As soon as she stepped out of the phone room, a guard recognized her, made her go back to the trailer where all the other moms were with the ICE officers. When she gets there, the officers looked pissed at everyone.
当伊雷特在打电话时，警卫开始寻找她。他们把她的名字和照片贴在整个设施周围的屏幕上。当她走出电话室时，一名警卫认出了她，让她回到其他母亲和ICE官员所在的拖车里。当她到达那里时，官员们看起来对每个人都很生气。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
And the other moms were saying, "No one sign. No one sign," signaling for everybody to not sign. And I'm going to be honest. I was telling the others that were there to not sign.
其他的母亲都在说，“没人签名。没人签名，”示意每个人都不要签。而且我要诚实。我当时在告诉在那里的人们不要签。
So, just to be clear, did you sign?
所以，明确一下，你签了吗？
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
No.
没有。
As a parent, you're supposed to be the one in charge. It's an unspoken pact between you and your kid. You're the one who decides things. But in detention, so much was out of Yiret's control. This was a rare moment where she got to at least say no.
作为父母，你应该是负责任的那个人。这是你和孩子之间不成文的契约。你是做决定的人。但在拘留中，太多事情超出了伊雷特的掌控。这是一个罕见的时刻，她至少能够说“不”。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I felt like I had an authority at that moment, when I was saying that to them. But from then on, I felt-- you know how I felt? I felt like I was trembling. Like, this trembling took over my body.
当我对他们说出这话时，我感到自己拥有了一种权威。但从那以后，我感到——你知道我感觉如何吗？我感到我在颤抖。就像，这种颤抖控制了我的身体。
Why?
为什么？
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Because I felt like I was defying an authority, and I never thought that I would do something like that. You know, they're the Department of ICE, and you can't say no to them if they decide to kick you out of the country. I mean, we're in their hands.
因为我感觉我在反抗权威，而且我从没想过我会做那种事。你知道，他们是移民局，如果他们决定把你踢出这个国家，你不能对他们说不。我的意思是，我们在他们的手中。
I reached out to ICE multiple times about this, but they haven't responded. But the lawyers I talked to have a theory about why the ICE officers were doing this, though. The government isn't supposed to detain kids longer than 20 days.
我多次就此事联系ICE，但他们没有回应。但我谈过的律师们有一个关于ICE官员为什么要这样做的理论。政府不允许拘留儿童超过20天。
But some families have been in detention for months. There's this federal judge, Judge Dolly Gee, who has been basically yelling at ICE about this for a while. She keeps getting more and more annoyed. And the court deadline was coming up.
但一些家庭已经被拘留了几个月。有一位联邦法官，多莉·吉法官，一直在为此对ICE大喊大叫。她越来越感到恼火。法庭截止日期快到了。
So the lawyers think ICE was trying to cover their ass. Ask parents if they were willing to separate from their kids. And when they said no, well, they could tell the judge, it's the family's fault. They won't release the kids. So we have to keep everyone in detention. But once a question like, do you want your kids to be separated from you, is said, you can't really hear it. It becomes part of your world.
所以律师们认为ICE是在试图推卸责任。询问父母是否愿意与孩子分开。当他们说不时，好吧，他们可以告诉法官，这是家庭的错。他们不释放孩子。所以我们必须把所有人关在拘留所里。但一旦像“你愿意与你的孩子分开吗”这样的问题被提出来，你就无法真正不去听它。它成了你世界的一部分。
For days after this happened, Alejandro and his friends couldn't stop talking about it. They kept asking each other's moms if they had signed. Alejandro asked Yiret, too. She kept saying, no, you know I didn't. You were there.
在这件事发生后的几天里，亚历杭德罗和他的朋友们对此谈论个不停。他们不断询问其他孩子的母亲是否签了字。亚历杭德罗也问了伊雷特。她一直说，不，你知道我没签。你当时在场。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
He was just scared. Look, he would sleep with me. This kid, he couldn't even go to the playroom to play because he was scared that ICE was going to grab him and take him.
他只是害怕。看，他会和我睡在一起。这个孩子，他甚至不敢去游戏室玩，因为他害怕ICE会抓住他带走。
And sometimes, I'd tell him, "Son, go grab a-- go grab some milk." And he said, "No, mom, the officers are there, and they could take me." And he would sometimes even scream in his sleep.
有时，我会告诉他，“儿子，去拿——去拿些牛奶。”他说，“不，妈妈，警卫在那里，他们可能会带走我。”他有时甚至会在睡梦中尖叫。
And so I'd ask him, "What's wrong?" And he'd say, "Mom, I'm scared. Don't sleep," he'd tell me, "because that's when they're going to take me."
所以我问他，“怎么了？”他说，“妈妈，我很害怕。别睡，”他会告诉我，“因为那是他们要带走我的时候。”
For what it's worth, as far as I can tell, when presented with the option of letting their kid out or being stuck together in detention, every single family chose to stay. All the lawyers I talked to-- and they represent almost every single family in these facilities-- they told me they didn't know of anyone who agreed to separate. Better to be alone together. At least this was a loneliness they knew.
不管怎样，据我所知，当被提供“让孩子离开”或“一起困在拘留所”的选择时，每一个家庭都选择了留下。我谈过的所有律师——他们代表了这些设施中几乎每一个家庭——都告诉我，他们不知道有谁同意分开。宁愿“在一起孤独”。至少这是他们知道的一种孤独。
Nadia Reiman is one of the producers of our show. Alejandro and his mom did finally get released seven weeks ago, but it had nothing to do with the judge's order. Alejandro had to have his appendix out, and they couldn't care for him at the facility.
纳迪亚·雷曼是我们节目的制作人之一。亚历杭德罗和他的母亲确实在七周前获释了，但这与法官的命令毫无关系。亚历杭德罗必须切除阑尾，而他们无法在设施内照顾他。
The judge has extended the deadline for ICE to figure out what to do with kids who have been detained longer than 20 days. ICE has until the end of the month.
法官延长了ICE处理那些被拘留超过20天的儿童问题的截止日期。ICE要在月底前完成。
We've arrived at Act Four, Applied Bob Studies. Can we take a moment to review some of the negative connotations the word "isolation" brings up? Think of the penalty box or solitary confinement.
我们来到了第四幕，应用鲍勃研究。我们可以花点时间回顾一下“隔离”这个词带来的负面含义吗？想想禁闭室或单独监禁。
But what if that isolation is a choice you make? Does that aloneness feel like something very different? I spoke to someone with an idea of the answer to that question-- writer Sandy Allen. The story begins in 2017.
但如果这种隔离是你做出的选择呢？那种孤独感感觉会非常不同吗？我和一个对这个问题有答案的人谈过——作家桑迪·艾伦。故事始于2017年。
Sandy was living in Brooklyn with an increasing feeling that they wanted to live closer to nature. It wasn't that they'd fallen out of love with cities. This was less about running away than it was about actively running toward something-- something green and lush. And on top of that, Sandy was beginning to come out as a non-binary.
桑迪住在布鲁克林，内心渴望更接近自然的感觉越来越强烈。并不是说他们不再爱城市。这与其说是逃离，不如说是积极地奔向某处——一片绿色茂盛的地方。最重要的是，桑迪开始以非二元性别的身份出柜。
I think I was just starting to play with such things as dressing a little more androgynously and leaving the house and/or going to a barbershop for men and getting a haircut there and trying to kind of like violate that taboo and not feel too weird if all these men were staring at me as I got a haircut.
我想我只是刚开始尝试一些事情，比如穿得稍微中性一点，出门，和/或去男士理发店理发，试图以某种方式打破那种禁忌，如果这些男人盯着我看我理发，我不会感觉太奇怪。
In those months of change, they'd begun to notice how their very appearance seemed to make the air charged.
在那些变化的月份里，他们开始注意到他们本人的外表似乎让空气变得紧张。
I had shifted from appearing like a certain thing in public, which was like a white woman, to appearing like this other thing, which was this white-- I don't know. Like, are you a dude or what?
我的外表从公共场合的一种状态——像一个白人女性——变成了这种东西，这种白人——我不知道。就像，你是男的还是什么？
And I was, I think, all of the time becoming more and more aware of everybody who saw me, and what did I look like to them, and how much of a threat was a random woman in a woman's room going to be to me. Was I going to get weird looks? Was I going to get yelled at? Was I going to get hostile comments muttered at me?
我想，我一直越来越意识到每一个看到我的人，我在他们眼里是什么样子，而一个随机的女性在女性洗手间对我来说会有多大的威胁。我会得到奇怪的目光吗？会被叫喊吗？会被嘟囔敌意的评论吗？
And I'm a sensitive flower. I'm a very, like-- I really-- I don't know. I'm very sensitive to people's feelings and emotions. And so I think there was a sense of, it would probably be wiser for me to cut down on the volume of interactions that I have with strangers.
而且我是一朵敏感的花。我非常，像——我真的——我不知道。我对人们的感受和情绪非常敏感。所以我认为有一种感觉是，减少我与陌生人互动量对我来说可能更明智。
But Sandy had at their fingertips an example of how to handle the situation, their Uncle Bob. At some point, he'd also decided that the volume of interactions in his life was way too big. And he took decisive, radical action. He moved a few hours away from where he'd grown up in the Bay Area to somewhere farther up north, a place mostly free of other humans.
但桑迪手头有一个如何处理这种情况的例子，那就是他们的鲍勃叔叔。在某个时候，他也决定了他生命中的互动量太大了。他采取了果断、激进的行动。他从在湾区长大的地方搬到了北边几个小时路程的地方，一个基本没有其他人类的地方。
Sandy had known Bob as a sort of weird figure who lived a mostly solitary existence. Sometimes they'd see him at Christmas or at their grandfather's vacation home in northern Minnesota. Bob liked to have long conversations, and sometimes he'd leave long, rambling messages on Sandy's family's answering machine, playing his music or comedy skits.
桑迪一直把鲍勃视为一个过着基本孤独生活的奇怪人物。有时他们会在圣诞节或他们祖父在明尼苏达州北部的度假屋见到他。鲍勃喜欢进行长时间的谈话，有时他会给桑迪家人的答录机留下长长的、漫无边际的信息，播放他的音乐或喜剧小品。
Growing up, Sandy didn't see Bob as a kindred spirit. In a family that didn't talk directly about things, Bob was an incomplete picture, an example of failure. As a teenager, Bob had been given the psychiatric diagnosis of schizophrenia and was repeatedly hospitalized and prescribed antipsychotic medication, sometimes against his will.
成长过程中，桑迪并不把鲍勃视为志同道合的人。在一个不直接谈论事情的家庭里，鲍勃是一个不完整的画面，一个失败的例子。十几岁时，鲍勃被诊断出患有精神分裂症，并多次住院并被开抗精神病药物，有时是在违背意愿的情况下。
In family lore, he was kind of this troubled guy, who'd got kicked out of high school and then bounced between psych hospitals and friends' couches. Sandy and Bob weren't close. And then, one day, in 2009, just as Sandy had started grad school in Iowa, they got a package in the mail. Bob had written his autobiography and sent it to them.
在家庭传说中，他有点像那个麻烦的家伙，被高中开除，然后在精神病院和朋友的沙发之间跳来跳去。桑迪和鲍勃并不亲近。然后，有一天，在2009年，就在桑迪刚开始在爱荷华州读研时，他们收到了一个包裹。鲍勃写了他的自传并寄给了他们。
I initially got this text in the mail from my hermit uncle that was typed in all caps on a typewriter and 60 pages. And it had swear words and slurs, and it was a mess. And it was-- I was just like, what is this? I don't want this, you know?
我最初收到这封邮寄的来自我隐士叔叔的文本，是用打字机全部大写打出来的，有60页。里面有脏话和污蔑，一团糟。而且是——我当时想，这是什么？我不需要这个，你知道吗？
And at the time, I would have thought, OK, this guy-- as I would have called him way back, my crazy Uncle Bob-- my crazy Uncle Bob and me, we are as far apart as two people can be. I would have thought in my heart, here I am. I am a scholastic achiever.
当时，我会想，好吧，这个家伙——正如我很久以前称呼他的，我那疯狂的鲍勃叔叔——我和我那疯狂的鲍勃叔叔，我们就像两个人之间那样遥远。我心里会想，我在这儿。我是一名学术成就者。
And here's Uncle Bob, who lives in the desert. And I've been to his house once, and it was full of cigarette smoke and bibles and a TV that he hadn't turned off in decades. And I kind of got out of there and was like, all right, I don't really need to know that guy.
而这里是住在沙漠里的鲍勃叔叔。我去过他家一次，那里满是烟味和圣经，还有一台他几十年来都没关过的电视。我逃离了那里，心想，好吧，我真的不需要认识那个家伙。
But then Sandy got to reading the manuscript. And they didn't just read it. They dove into it, tried to figure out who Bob was, even started writing a book about him.
但随后桑迪读到了手稿。他们不只是读了它。他们潜入其中，试图弄清楚鲍勃是谁，甚至开始写一本关于他的书。
And they discovered something. Bob had solved for himself a problem that his mental health professionals and the world in general hadn't been able to. Bob had managed to bring out the best version of his life, living alone, far away from the crush of people. And Sandy found that Bob was mostly content.
他们发现了一件事。鲍勃为自己解决了一个他的心理健康专家乃至整个世界都未能解决的问题。鲍勃成功地过上了他生命中最好的版本，独自生活，远离人群。桑迪发现鲍勃基本上是满足的。
And I saw that as a model for, like, OK, you've realized you're incompatible with society at large, perhaps. So what do you do? I was like, well, I kind of have a guidebook here.
我把它视为一个模型，就像，好吧，你意识到你与大社会是不相容的，也许。那你该怎么办？我当时想，好吧，我这里有一本指南。
And so they took Bob's example and moved. In 2017, Sandy and their boyfriend, now husband, moved upstate to the Catskills. They weren't under any romantic illusions about country living.
于是他们遵循了鲍勃的例子搬走了。2017年，桑迪和他们的男友，现在的丈夫，搬到了上州的卡茨基尔山。他们对乡村生活没有任何浪漫的幻想。
It's like, if I go to a grocery store or I go to the post office, an old man would stare at me the whole time I grocery shopped. Or little kids would debate what gender I was in front of me. You know what I mean? That kind of stuff could happen here, just as well as it could happen anywhere.
就像，如果我去杂货店或邮局，一个老头会盯着我购物。或者小孩子会在我面前争论我的性别。你知道我的意思吗？那种事可能发生在这里，就像可能发生在任何地方一样。
And there isn't really anywhere where I think I feel entirely safe, other than my house, [LAUGHS] which is why I like my house so much.
而且我觉得我不认为有哪个地方是完全安全的，除了我的房子，[笑]这就是为什么我那么喜欢我的房子。
Tell me about your setup then. So how isolated is life up there, really?
那告诉我你的设置。所以在那里的生活实际上有多隔绝？
So when we moved here where I sit on my front porch, I don't see another human dwelling. It's very much like my neighbors are trees, and trees and trees and trees. It's just-- it's astonishingly beautiful in a million ways every day. I mean, I think that is mental health care.
当我们搬到这里，我坐在前廊时，我看不到另一个人类住所。简直就像我的邻居是树，树，还是树。它只是——每天在一百万种方式上都惊人地美丽。我的意思是，我认为那就是心理健康护理。
Before COVID-19, Sandy's husband traveled a lot for work. Sometimes Sandy was alone for weeks at a time. It felt incredibly challenging at times, especially early on.
新冠疫情前，桑迪的丈夫工作经常出差。有时桑迪会独自待上几周。这有时感觉非常具有挑战性，尤其是在早期。
I was like, oh, no. I felt like, oh, what did I just do? Like, I've replaced people with trees. I had that feeling of like, oh, no, I'm going to have no friends. And then I remembered Bob. And I remembered, well, Bob didn't let living in the desert stop him from having friends.
我当时想，噢，不。我感觉，噢，我刚才做了什么？就像，我用树代替了人。我有那种感觉，就像，噢，不，我将没有朋友。然后我想起了鲍勃。我想起，好吧，鲍勃并没有让生活在沙漠中阻止他拥有朋友。
Bob built a system for himself, where he interacted with people, but not so many and not so much that it became unwanted noise in his head. He was only as alone as he needed to be. It turns out Bob, a man who proudly called himself a hermit, living only with his two dogs, was actually something of a social savant.
鲍勃为自己建立了一个系统，他与人互动，但不多，也不会吵到让他头脑中出现不必要的噪音。他只是在需要的时候才孤独。结果证明鲍勃，一个自豪地自称“隐士”、只和两条狗生活的男人，实际上是一个社交专家。
I think in Bob's specific case, it totally surprised me. I got on the phone with every person who had known him, who I could possibly find, who would talk to me. And everybody who I found, everybody I spoke with was like, you will not believe it. Bob used to call all the time. Bob would stay in touch.
我想在鲍勃的具体案例中，这完全让我惊讶。我给所有我知道的认识他的人打了电话，我能找到的、愿意和我谈的人。每一个我找到的、每一个我交谈过的人都说，你不会相信的。鲍勃过去常常打电话来。鲍勃会保持联系。
And I was kind of like, isn't that funny how a norm here seems to be, if you're physically isolated, you have to really cut off from people? And I think Bob, if anything, because of the life he'd led and all of the ways in which I think he was a lonely person, he was actually, I think, really adept at overcoming maybe that little voice inside your head that says, all right, don't reach out. You know, like, don't do that. That would be weird, or whatever.
我有点想，这里的常态似乎是，如果你物理上被隔离了，你就必须真正与人切断联系，这难道不滑稽吗？我认为鲍勃，如果有的话，因为他过去的生活和他我认为他作为一个孤独的人的所有方式，实际上，我认为，他非常善于克服你脑海里那个说“好吧，不要联系了”的小声音。你知道，像，不要那样做。那会很奇怪，什么的。
Like, Bob was not worried about that. He was calling people. And I think it's forced me in a way to-- I don't know-- not really accept physical isolation as an excuse for being disconnected. I try to tell myself, like, hey, don't just stop talking to people because you live out here. It's something that you have to invest in.
就像，鲍勃不担心那个。他在给人们打电话。我认为这在某种程度上强迫了我——我不知道——不要真的接受物理隔离作为与人断开联系的借口。我试着对自己说，嘿，不要因为你住在这里就停止与人交谈。这是你必须投资的东西。
Sandy wanted to learn how to be alone, and how to do it comfortably. In their words, "to just hang out with themself." And Bob provided a model. His big three tenets were creativity, community, and spirituality.
桑迪想学会如何独处，以及如何舒服地做到这一点。用他们的话说，“只是和自己待在一起”。鲍勃提供了一个模型。他的三大原则是创造力、社区和灵性。
Bob was like this just example I had kind of in my head of like, OK, you're alone. What are you going to do about it? You know what to do. Bob showed you. Like, it's not the same stuff. I don't read the Bible and play the guitar and watch Joel Osteen and call my cousin, Jane. I don't do the same stuff that Bob did. I do call Jane. But I had to figure out what are my versions of read the Bible, play guitar.
鲍勃就像我脑海里的一个例子，像，好吧，你孤独了。你要怎么办？你知道该怎么办。鲍勃给你展示了。就像，这不一样。我不读圣经，不弹吉他，不看乔尔·欧斯汀，不给我的堂姐简打电话。我不做鲍勃做过的事。我确实给简打电话。但我必须弄清楚我读圣经、弹吉他的版本是什么。
Their version of that was singing and playing the piano, baking bread, and, where possible, growing food and sharing it with their small community.
他们的版本是唱歌、弹钢琴、烤面包，以及在可能的情况下种植食物并与他们的小社区分享。
Would you say that you've ended up getting what you wanted? Would you-- did it make your life better in the ways that you hoped it would?
你会说你最终得到了你想要的吗？你会——它以你希望的方式改善了你的生活吗？
Oh, I mean, honestly, Bim, I don't even remember what the world was before. I mean, I feel like my whole consciousness began about three years ago when I moved to this house.
噢，我的意思是，诚实地说，本，我都不记得世界以前是什么样了。我的意思是，我感觉我的整个意识大约始于三年前我搬到这房子的时候。
Wow.
哇。
I don't know.
我不知道。
That is a big thing to say.
那是一件很大的话。
Is that weird? I don't remember. For me, this is my whole universe now, is like this place, the weather here today and what's going on in my garden. I think I've just, like-- yeah, I've had a full head transplant of some kind. Even since the first afternoon I was here, I was just like, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes. This is what I want to be doing.
那很奇怪吗？我不记得了。对我来说，这就是我的整个宇宙，就像这个地方，这里今天的天气，还有我的花园里正在发生什么。我想我只是——是的，我进行了一种全身心的移植。即使从我到这里的第一天下午开始，我就想，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的。这就是我想做的事情。
Sandy is not alone-- not really. The same way Bob wasn't either. Instead, they're in a sort of self-governing isolation, which is different to the misery of COVID-19 driving us into our own homes indefinitely. Sandy's isolation is completely under their control. They looked squarely at aloneness and made decisions about how to manage it.
桑迪并不孤独——并不是真的。就像鲍勃也不是。相反，他们处在一种自我管理的隔离中，这与新冠疫情迫使我们无限期进入自己家的那种痛苦是不同的。桑迪的隔离完全在他们的控制之下。他们直面孤独，并就如何管理它做出了决定。
Alone is one of those words that I immediately kind of wonder, aren't we all alone? Is there anybody who does not feel very alone? I would love to meet that person. There's stuff that can make that even more profound. And I think when you're queer-- or trans maybe, too-- you just know that some people aren't going to be in your life forever.
“孤独”是我立刻会产生疑问的词之一，我们不都是孤独的吗？有没有谁不感到非常孤独？我很想见见那样的人。有些东西可以让那变得更深刻。而且我认为当你是一个酷儿——或者也许是跨性别——时，你只知道有些人不会永远出现在你的生命中。
For me, coming out has entailed a fair amount of social loss. As long as you're alive, you're going to have to contend with being inside your head, being inside your story, being inside the world, which is full of prejudice and bullshit.
对我来说，出柜带来了相当多的社交损失。只要你还活着，你就必须应对待在自己的脑海里，待在自己的故事里，待在世界上，它充满了偏见和废话。
I think that for me, that really thinking about not let's solve it all, or like, how will I combat loneliness forever. Definitely, I've had these moments where I'm like, wow, I've really set myself up to just be alone. I've tried to kind of give myself permission to embrace, yeah, I'm weird, you know? I'm not normal. I've never been normal.
我认为对我来说，那真的在思考，不要让我们解决这一切，或者，我将如何永远与孤独抗争。我肯定，我有过这样的时刻，就像，哇，我真的为自己设置了只待在孤独中。我试着给自己某种许可去拥抱，是的，我很奇怪，你知道吗？我不正常。我从来不正常。
There was never a moment of my life when I understood whatever a person who was assigned woman at birth or man at birth and just feels that way-- I don't know what that is. I've never known what that is.
我生命中从来没有一个时刻理解那些被指派为女性或男性出生并就感觉如此的人——我不知道那是什么。我从来不知道那是什么。
So for me, it's so freeing to just be like, yeah, I live in the country by myself for the most part. And I can walk around topless. And I've had top surgery. And I don't care if anyone drives by and sees my scars. This is who I am. And life is glorious. And let's show up for it, you know?
所以对我来说，能仅仅像“是的，我大体上独自住在乡下。我可以赤裸上身走路。我做过上半身手术。我不在乎是否有人开车经过看到我的疤痕”那样自由太棒了。这就是我。生命是辉煌的。让我们为它出现吧，你知道吗？
Bob wasn't sitting in the desert, going, oh, woe is me. I'm sure he had minutes and days where he felt that way. I think he did sometimes get really down about some of the experiences that he had in his life. Especially the first time he was in a hospital, I think a lot of stuff happened to him that really was hard. And I think he also was someone who, despite a lot, figured out how to sit down at his typewriter or pick up his guitar and continue on.
鲍勃并没有坐在沙漠里，去说，噢，我真可怜。我相信他会有感觉那样的几分钟和几天。我想他有时确实会对他在生活中经历的一些事情感到非常沮丧。尤其是他第一次住院时，我想发生在他身上的一些事情真的很艰难。而且我想他也是一个尽管有很多经历，但仍然想出如何坐在打字机前或拿起吉他继续前进的人。
Sandy Allen, their book about their Uncle Bob is called A Kind of Miraculous Paradise, A True Story About Schizophrenia.
桑迪·艾伦，他们关于鲍勃叔叔的书名为《一种奇迹般的天堂，关于精神分裂症的真实故事》。
[MUSIC - "ALONE AGAIN" BY BOBBY OROZA]
[音乐 - 鲍比·奥罗扎的“再次孤独”]
Our program was produced today by me and Nadia Reiman. People who worked on today's show include Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Noor Gill, Damien Graves, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker.
今天的节目由我和纳迪亚·雷曼制作。参与今天节目的还有苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔洪、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德、努尔·吉尔、达米安·格雷夫斯、米基·米克、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和朱莉·惠特克。
Our managing editors are Sarah Abdurrahman and Diane Wu. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum. Special thanks today to Rob Rosenthal, Melissa Flores, Shay Fluharty, Bridget Cambria, Andrea Meza, Leroy Chiao, Julia Furlan, Jami Sunkel, Christopher W. Clark of the Cornell Lab of Ornithology, Laela Sayigh, and Woods Hole Oceanographic Institution.
我们的执行编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼和黛安·吴。我们的主编是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。今天特别感谢罗布·罗森塔尔、梅丽莎·弗洛雷斯、谢伊·弗鲁哈蒂、布里奇特·坎布里亚、安德烈·梅扎、勒罗伊·焦、朱莉娅·弗兰、杰米·桑克尔、康奈尔鸟类学实验室的克里斯托弗·W·克拉克、莱拉·赛伊和伍兹霍尔海洋研究所。
You can hear the original version of Lilly's story about the whale that may or may not be lonely at transom.org, a website that gives people the tools and inspiration to make their own Public Radio. Lilly made this as part of a training they offer called the Transom Story Workshop. Visit transom.org to learn about their workshops and to check out all the resources they offer.
你可以在transom.org上听到莉莉关于鲸鱼是否孤独的原始故事版本，这是一个为人们提供工具和灵感来制作自己的公共广播的网站。莉莉是作为他们提供的名为“Transom故事工作室”的培训的一部分制作的。访问transom.org了解他们的工作坊并查看他们提供的所有资源。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks to our show's usual host, Ira Glass. You know, he has Netflix, but not HBO Max, which led to a horrible realization about his favorite sitcom.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX分发给公共广播电台。感谢我们节目的常规主持人艾拉·格拉斯。你知道，他有Netflix，但没有HBO Max，这导致了他关于他最喜爱的电视情景喜剧的一个可怕的发现。
I had that feeling of like, oh, no, I'm going to have no friends.
我有着那种感觉，就像，噢，不，我将没有朋友。
I'm Bim Adewunmi. We'll be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是本·阿德温米。下周我们将带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。
[MUSIC - "ALONE AGAIN" BY BOBBY OROZA]
[音乐 - 鲍比·奥罗扎的“再次孤独”]